It's,
it's unbelievable the degree to which
our sanity depends on our functioning,
sociological structure and,
and here's why.
Well,
first of all,
you kind of need to know what to do
every day.
You have to have a routine because
you're an animal,
you know,
and you know if you have a dog or a cat,
dogs are really good example of this.
Dogs like routine,
they like to be walked the number of
times a day that they're supposed to be
walked and they get quite sick very
rapidly.
If you don't,
if you don't routinize their days,
children are exactly the same way.
Now you can overdo it,
right?
But still,
you know,
you need to know approximately when you
should get up,
should be approximately the same
everyday.
You need to know approximately.
You're going,
when you're going to eat,
you need to know what you're going to
eat.
You need to know who you're going to eat
with.
You need to know where to buy your food.
It's like 80 percent of your life,
70 percent of your life.
Something like that consists of those
things that you do every single day that
you repeat,
and those are often the things that
people think about as the trivial
elements of their life,
but one of the things I would like to
point out to you if you do the
mathematics I,
I did this with a client of mine who was
having a hard time putting his child to
bet they were having a fight every night
and I knew by that time the studies
indicate that most parents only spend 20
minutes per day of one on one time with
their child.
Now the reason for that is that people
are busy and it's actually not that easy
to parse out 20 minutes of one on one
time.
It's a lot bloody more time than you
think,
but that's all there is.
Twenty minutes and he's spending like 40
minutes a day fighting with his kid,
trying to get the kid to go to bed and
that's not very entertaining.
You know,
you think,
well,
it's just having a scrap with a kid
about going to bed,
but it's.
No,
no,
no.
If it happens every day,
it's a catastrophe,
so you do the math,
so we'll say five hours a week for the
sake of argument,
just to keep it simple.
It's 20 hours a month,
it's 240 hours a year.
That's 60 slash 40 hour work weeks,
so that guy was basically spending a
month and a half of work weeks doing
absolutely nothing but having a wretched
time fighting with his son,
trying to get them to go to bed.
Horrible,
right?
That's just way too much time to spend
doing something like that.
If you want to actually have a positive
relationship with someone because it's
just too.
It's just too punishing and so well,
so you need structure,
you need predictability and you need
more of it than you think just to keep
you sane.
Now,
if you're lucky and and maybe a bit odd,
you can deviate five percent from the
norm or 10 percent from the norm or
something like that carefully and
cautiously.
As long as the rest of you is all well
ordered,
an informative manner,
you might be able to get away with that
and you might be able to sustain that
across time and people might be able to
tolerate you if you do it or maybe
you'll get really lucky and you happen
to be creative but reasonably well put
together and people will actually be
happy that there's something
idiosyncratic and unique about you.
But even under those circumstances,
mostly what you want is to have a
routine.
It's disciplined,
that's predictable and bloody well stick
to it.
You're going to be way healthier and
happier and Saner if you do that.
And then the other thing that you need,
because this is one of the things the
psychoanalyst got wrong,
I think is that they overestimated the
degree to which sanity was a consequence
of internal,
of being properly structured internally.
You know,
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view,
you're sort of an ego and that ego is
inside you and of course it rests on an
unconscious structure.
But the purpose of psychoanalytic
analysis is to sort out that unconscious
structure and the ego on top of it and
to make you a fully functioning and
autonomous individual,
but there's a problem with that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and antonymous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche,
even though that's important.
The reason that you're saying,
if you're aware,
if you have a well organized unconscious
and ego is because other people can
tolerate having you around for
reasonably extensive periods of time and
we'll cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue,
and so what people are doing to each
other all the time,
just nonstop is broadcasting.
Sanity signals back and forth,
right?
It's like you smile at people.
If they're well,
if they're not only behaving property
but behaving in a way that you would
like to see them continue to behave,
you frown at them.
If they're not,
you ignore them.
you shun them.
You,
you roll your eyes out them.
You manifested disgust face.
You don't listen to them,
you interrupt them,
you won't cooperate with them,
you won't compete with them.
It's like you're blasting signals of
other people about how to regulate their
behavior so frequently.
Well,
it just makes up all of your social
interaction and that's why we face each
other and we have emotional displays on
her face and we're looking at each
other's eyes and we know exactly we know
as much as we can about what's going on
with each other given that we don't have
immediate access to the contents of
their consciousness.
And so partly what you're doing with
your routine is establishing yourself as
a credible,
reliable,
trustworthy,
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape,
making sure that that's exactly what you
are and that's how you stay sane.
And so what happens to people too,
if they don't have a routine and they
get isolated as they start to drift and
they drift badly because the world is
too complicated for you to keep it
organized all by yourself.
You just cannot do it.
So a lot of our,
so we outsource the problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
outsourced the problem of sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem.
And so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have a
very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem all the
time.